I went to the bank the other day,
socially safe, of course, wearing my mask,
and the tellers told me,
and this is something that's interesting
'cause it's sort of a
nationwide phenomenon.
They told me they had run out of coins.
Did you know this was going on?
Apparently we're going
through a coin shortage.
Yeah, you see it in lots
of different stores.
They say no change. I guess
it's like a COVID thing.
Yeah, well anyway, the
US Mint is scrambling
to figure out just what to do
and they just released this ad.
Take a look.
Hi, I'm Diana Fowler,
Director of the US Mint.
As an unforeseen side effect
of COVID-19, for some reason,
America is also now experiencing
a shortage of coins.
(laughs) We don't know why either.
So we're introducing a
replacement for coins.
Coibs.
Coibs are just like coins,
except they're actually small rocks.
[Man] Ah!
It's a rock! (laughing)
Coibs are about the same size as coins
and they come from the ground,
which means we're less
likely to run out of them.
And from now on all
businesses have to take them
as legal tender.
Coibs.
It's a new thing we're trying
because we ran out of coins.
Sorry, can you cut?
I'm Glenn, a writer at Conan.
Does this sketch idea like
even make sense at all?
Oh
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, it's great.
Yeah, I've just been
spending a lot of time inside
by myself with like no one else around.
And since my brain just went, like,
what if, what if coins were rocks?
Well, and like read the
news at all right now,
like it's hard to be
creative and make stuff.
Oh, absolutely. I totally get it.
Totally, yes.
Of course.
Oh my God I totally, like me,
I'm trying to finish this novel.
So my creative brain is not a little bit
not doing good stuff 'cause
I'm just so isolated right now
that I think I'm going crazy.
No, no, no, absolutely not.
Not losing your mind. I swear.
The concept of the
sketch is a little weird.
It's kind of it's a little, I mean, yeah.
Yeah.
What is it funner if coins were bugs
(laughing) that a good idea
Oh, that's funny.
That's good
That's very fresh
That makes sense. Okay.
That's oh yeah
Thank you.
Actor. Whose name?
I don't remember. Okay.
Hi. I'm from the U S mint
and coins is bugs now.
Slow music
Now I enjoyed that.
Didn't you, Andy?
Yeah, it was good.
Yeah. I think everyone enjoyed it.
Oh
okay.
Great.